The Joe Rogan experience. You know, I've gone through, again,
all these iterations of trying to, um,
assist people with the information that I've come across in my research on how
they can achieve an ideal body composition, have more energy, um, maintain or,
or build, uh, you know, muscle, um, improve their immune systems,
have better sex, be more, whatever it is.
These are the things that these are what I'm trying to, um, the,
the hidden genetic switches that I'm trying to uncover for people. And in, in,
so doing, you can choose to do it or not.
I'm not suggesting you have to do this to have a great life,
but here are some of the ways that we do it.
And it started with a primal blueprint and then sort of morphed it into, well,
the primal blueprint works really well for a lot of people and even worked well
for me, but is there something else, is there a new like level I could get to?
And that was the keto. So I,
I wrote a book called the keto reset diet since I was on here. And I was,
I was in the keto for a while, but then I, I sort of said, well, you know,
keto is not a way to live your life. It's a, it's a tool,
a strategy that you can use is to build metabolic flexibility. Some
People do think that it's a way to live your life though. Like, you know,
domino. Yeah. He, he, he does it all the time.
Yeah. I mean, I have a lot of friends who do, who do keto the whole time.
I'm just, I'm not a person who says, that's the way ketos the, you know,
the be all and the end, all of how you should live your life, because I'm,
I'm more about achieving metabolic flexibility. And,
and that's a term that's come up in the last couple of years.
I dunno if you've heard it,
but it basically describes your body's ability to extract energy from whatever
substrate is available at the time. So.
Making it easier for your body to bounce back and forth from fat to
carbohydrates, it not requires so much of a gap. Bingo.
Cause usually the gap is what is like two weeks or so.
Something like that for you, if you're a carbohydrate.
Yeah. And if you're, and if, and if you never go down the route of,
of keto and all you do is eat carbs your whole life,
or have a carb centric diet,
you never get to the point where you're burning fat, efficiently or effectively,
right? So you're, you're really metabolically inflexible.
Your body is just demanding that it continuously run on carbs and never tapping
into your fat stores. So you get typically you get incrementally,
fatter and fatter. Um, and then if you skip a meal or skip two meals,
or try to go on to some sort of a fast,
the wheels fall off because you haven't built a metabolic machinery to,
to burn fat, to burn ketones and, and all the things that go along with,
with metabolic flexibility. So it turns out Metabo flexibility,
the holy grail and how you get there, whether it's, uh, primal,
paleo, uh, vegetarian, vegan, uh, fasting,
if whatever, I don't, it's almost like it's, it doesn't matter what route you,
you use. If you can get to the point where you're metabolically flexible.
Now you have this ability to,
to extract energy from your own stored body fat whenever you don't eat. And how.
Does one do that? Like, what's the best strategy? Well.
The best strategy is keto.
So that's.
The best strategy for sure, for sure. That's the best strategy. So, um, because,
uh, as long as you keep feeding your body carbohydrates,
every two or three hours all day long, the body goes, Hey, I got,
I got plenty of fuel. Um,
taking the carbohydrates in raises my blood sugar,
blood sugar is a fuel, but I don't want too much of it in my system.
And so the body produces insulin,
which tries to take excess glucose and protein and fat out of
the bloodstream and sequester it in the cells. Um, and in,
so doing your blood sugar drops because it's it's,
and then you have to eat again every two or three hours.
And it's this cycle that people enter into that they,
that they're on for a lifetime sometimes. And, and the tendency over time,
because you're not burning your stored body fat who accumulate body fat.
You never get really adept at burning body fat. And you never,
because you never take time off to require that your body burns its fat.
You just keep accumulating it.
So how does someone go from being metabolically inflexible to
metabolically flexible without going into keto?
That's difficult. The way to do it is, is through fasting. Um, and it, it just,
keto is such a, a, a better way to do it.
And the reason is you you're trying to prompt the body into making
changes that it doesn't wanna make. Mm. You know,
when you go to the gym and you lift, wait,
you're prompting the body to build muscle that really doesn't want to bill,
but now you're, you know, you're giving it a reason to.
And so when you withhold carbohydrate from the diet and sugar in particular,
but carbohydrate in general, um,
and the body senses that it's not gonna get glucose for a while,
it starts to go to, uh, a plan B,
which is to build the metabolic machinery,
to start to extract energy from stored fat cells to burn that fat,
to combust that fat in the muscle cells. Uh,
it takes some of the fat sends it to the liver, uh,
and to convert into ketones because the brain works really well on ketones.
In fact,
the brain works better on ketones than it does on glucose for most people.
So the body has this a built-in plan, this diagram,
this genetic program that you're born with to be metabolically flexible,
and to be able to extract energy from fat and from ketones and from glucose.
Uh, and, and it would normally go that route, but we,
we never give it the reason to now, how, how is that, um, P plan?
How has it evolved? Well,
for most of human history we ate and we didn't eat it. Wasn't like,
you know, breakfast was the most important meal of the day,
or make sure you keep, you know, uh, little tougher wear things of, uh,
a little bit of protein and some carbohydrate to eat every two or three hours or
else your muscles go into cannibal mode. No humans are wired to overeat.
And because food was so scarce, when we did come across food, we tend to,
to eat more and certainly sweet foods like fruits was even more
palatable. So we probably tended to eat more of that. But,
but so we're wired to overeat and we have this amazing, uh,
design that allows us to take excess energy and convert it into
fuel that we carry around with us all the time,
conveniently located above the center of gravity. So it's on the hips,
on the butt, on the thighs, on the belly. So,
so we tend to carry this excess body fat as a survival mechanism from
a million years ago. That's.
Why you carry it here.
Yeah. That's sure that.
It's like a Fanny pack.
Yeah. It's exactly what it is. <laugh>, that's exactly what it is. So, so, but,
but again, if you look at evolution and how, and how things work were BI Peles,
we have to stand upright. So, you know, if we had, uh,
fat accumulating on our upper back or whatever, we'd be, you know, tipping over.
So it's conveniently located over the center. It's an elegant, elegant design.
The problem is it was designed so that when you didn't eat food,
you could take that same fuel, take it outta store, urge, combust it and,
and not be any of the worst for wear, not think of anything other than,
you know, I'm still gonna hunt. I'm still gonna do all these things.
I haven't eaten for five days. I'm not hunt hangry. I'm not off at my mate.
I'm just gonna keep going with a great attitude that I'm gonna find something to
eat.
Now. What is the standard amount of time?
Is there a standard amount of time between if a person that eats a normal
American diet and they just decide to fast,
how long does it take before their body to converts, to burning fat?
If they're not going keto, right? Yeah. Um, they're probably gonna burn,
they're gonna probably use a little bit of muscle in the pro because the
body, if, if it isn't used to, to, uh,
deriving most of its energy from fat,
because of a process that you've engaged in to, to use keto to, um,
you know, to, to burn fat, um, it'll, it'll still seek glucose.
And if you don't give it glucose and you haven't done this work for the first
couple of day, it's it's, it's miserable.
And so people talk about the low carb flu or the, um, or, you know,
if they go on a fasting thing at an Ashra, you know, I saw, I saw Elvis,
you know, two days ago and Elvis, whatever, Ash Ashra, whatever,
what I saw Elvis in my, in my dreams, oh, you're saying, cuz you're going crazy.
Cause you're going crazy. Right? So you're, you know, your, your, your,
your brain is kind of frazzled cuz you haven't given it the opportunity to,
to really thrive on keytones yet your, your body's making keytones,
but you haven't, again,
you haven't built that metabolic machinery to use them efficiently and
effectively. And so the brain's still looking for glucose and as a result,
what happens is the brain will send a signal to the adrenals,
to discreet cortisol, cortisol. Then you know,
goes throughout the body and strip amino acids from muscle tissue to send
them to the liver, to become glucose. So you can feed the brain. So it's,
it's counterproductive over time. And it's also, you know,
one of the reasons why back in the old body building days in the old,
in the old training days in any gym, this,
this mantra about don't go more than three or three or four hours without eating
or you'll cannibalize your muscle tissue.
If you haven't become fat adapted and keto adapted, that does happen.
You do cannibalize muscle tissue. When you go long periods of time without.
Eating, like I say, when I say standard American diet, I don't mean junk food.
But if you're a person who eats normal, eat a little bit of pasta,
a little bit of bread, but you eat mostly healthy. Yeah.
If you decide that you're going to fast,
your body's gonna cannibalize some muscle, not so much.
How much.
I, a few pounds depends.
Not, you know, a few pounds, maybe few pounds and you get it back.
You'll get it back. But the idea is that it, if you can weather that storm,
how much time are you looking for before your body starts burning fast?
Some people a week, some people two weeks, some people a week,
some people three weeks you'll.
Be dead. You can't fast.
For two weeks. Oh no, no. You're talking about fasting. Fasting. Oh Jesus.
No I'm talking about uh, no I'm not talking about no, no I'm talking.
No I'm talking about intermittent. No, that gets us to two meals a day.
Right. But what if, but what if someone one just fasts.
But so no. What? So give a term like.
Six. Yeah. I'm gonna go on a 36 hour fast.
That's probably the high end of what I would do. And then anything beyond that,
I'd be a little bit concerned that I hadn't prepped myself with,
with fat adaptation.
Yet. So when people go on these crazy three to five day fasts, they,
they report all this energy. They feel great. They feel amazing.
What's going on there? Well, they're.
They've got their brains are using keytones right.
So that's definitely where the energy, the feeling of amazing comes from. Um,
typically if you're fasting that long,
you're not working out like you like any of these,
like my wife does a seven day wall water fast. Oh Jesus. Twice a year.
Oh Jesus. That's what I said. Do you,
do you go on vacation when that's happening? No, <laugh>.
I eat more. I eat for her.
While she's gone. Why does she do that?
She has this, you know, she feels that like, it's, uh, good for her.
She's into the auto and the, and, and some of the, um, explain that.
Antiaging. It.
Burns cells that are, yeah. So this, when you're one of the things,
one of the many things that happens when you,
when you fast is that your body goes into a different mode and it starts to
realize that there's not gonna be a lot of fuel around for a while.
And so in addition to burning stored body fat, in addition to making ketones,
um, by the way, ketones come from fat.
So some of the fat that you combust is also just converted into keto tones,
that your brain can you use. Um, it also,
the body also says like, if you were to be a, if you had a, a brain,
if you were a cell and you had a brain, you thought, well,
generally there's a lot of fuel around.
So my job is to pass the genetic material along to the next generation.
So there's plenty for two of us. So I'll just divide and there'll be two of us.
That'd be great. That's same himself. When in the absence of,
of this sort of bathing in, in nutrition goes, well,
this not even enough for one of me, let alone two of me,
so I'm not gonna divide. I'm gonna repair what I have.
And so the cell goes into a repair process where it starts to consume damaged
proteins and damaged fats within itself. Uh, it, it,
and it actually gets energy from that, um, starts to repair, uh,
broken strands of DNA or whatever little things are going on.
It actually kills off esent cells at that time. So it's a,
it's an anti-aging strategy that a lot of people use. Um, it's also a God,
I hate the term reset. I gotta, I, why do you need.
A term? Cause.
It's overused. No, but, and I used it in a book,
but all of a sudden in the context of what's going on in the world and the great
reset, like I never want to hear that term again. Oh.
The great reset.
Isn't that that's the conspiracy theory that the government is using this to
change the financial structure of the country and everything else. Yeah.
Do you hear that a lot in Florida? Is that what's going on? No, no.
Don't sports.
Down there. Miami beach. No, no we don't. No, but I read a lot, Joe. I said,
yeah, I read the New York times to see what the other side's doing.
The great reason. Yeah. But, um, so, so she,
she will do these fast, but she's metabolically flexible.
So it's easy for her to do mm-hmm <affirmative> but if you're not metabolically
flexible and you try, you, you, you take on a fast of three days,
um, you can get through it and, and it's probably good for you.
My whole thing is I want this to be, if you chose to do something like that,
I want it to be pleasurable, pleasurable, and easy and graceful. And you know,
something you look forward to doing, not something you dread doing.
Now, is there, um, amount,
can you intermittent fast and get your body to be more metabolically flexible in
that way? Yeah.
That's and that's what I'm talking about. So,
so I'm not even into the multiday fasting, I'm into, um,
two meals a day. So the premise of the book is, um,
once you've developed metabolic flexibility to, um,
engage in as much time as you can of not eating throughout the day to maximize
all of these benefits that we just described that come from not eating.
And it,
one of the things we say is most of the good things happen to us when we're not
eating, you know, most of the repair, most of the recovery,
most of the rebuilding happen when we're not eating, when we're eating,
which we have to do. Um, it comes with inflammation and, and, you know, it's a,
it's a necessary thing, but the good stuff all happens when we're not eating.
So the, to the extent that we can,
we can expand that window of not eating and with,
with the two meals a day program.
And which pretty much anybody whose keto now does you just have an evening
meal and then you don't eat until one o'clock 1 32 o'clock the next
day. So you have two meals a day and you have that 18 hour window. That's your,
that's what you use an 18 hour window. Yeah. 18 hour window. Yeah. Why did.
You choose 18?
Um, it works for me. I mean, you can do 16, you can do. I mean,
anything less than, you know, 14 is back to sort of, you know,
where you were before. It's a little bit better, but it's not as, like I said,
the more time that you can go between eating the better and it,
and it isn't about a, uh, so much a routine on a daily basis.
It's basically, um, uh, I, I certainly use that as a template,
but once in a while I eat one meal a day, I'll go, you know, dinner to dinner,
to dinner. And the, the beauty here is because I'm metabolically flexible.
I have the confidence that I'm not tearing down muscle tissue. I have, uh,
that my immune system is probably benefiting from it as opposed to being a
somehow, um, hurt by it. Um, maintain muscle mass. Um,
again, I have all this energy and most importantly, I'm not hungry.
Catch new episodes. The Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify,
watch back catalog J E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data cost. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the J on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.